two nasa astronauts are back home in
houston after historic return
to earth their spacex dragon capsule
splashed down yesterday in the gulf of
mexico off the florida panhandle
it was the first splashdown by u.s
astronauts in 45 years
as mark strossman reports nasa wants to
know how sightseers
were able to get so close to the
spacecraft after splashdown
after 64 days in space astronauts bob
bankin
and doug hurley reunited with their
families sunday night
to be where we are now the first crude
flight
of dragon is just unbelievable
dragon spacex separation confirmed their
19-hour journey home began
saturday night more than 260 miles above
south africa crew dragon's fiery plummet
into earth's atmosphere
reached temperatures of around 3 500
degrees
blacking out communications for about
six minutes
in mission control spacex founder elon
musk
front row center waited anxiously to
hear from the crew
dragon spacex calm check
never has it under four giant parachutes
the capsule descended 15 miles per hour
splashing down in the warm gulf waters
splashdown welcome back to planet earth
and thanks for flying spacex
thank god you know
you know i'm not very religious but i
prayed for this one good evening the
last of the apollos
not since 1975 have american astronauts
return to earth
with a water landing right on time and
just about right on target
but apollo splashdowns never looked like
this
you are seeing a few more boats than
expected
more than a dozen recreational boaters
swarmed the capsule
ignoring coast guard warnings as crews
tried to recover it
and the astronauts inside something like
this just
really can endanger the whole thing nasa
administrator
jim bridenstine that was not what we
were anticipating the boats just made a
beeline for it there are things that
we're going to look at that we can do
better next time for sure
dragon looked like a giant charred
marshmallow
as it was hoisted aboard a spacex
recovery ship
bank and hurley were pulled from the
hatch all okay
before their launch in may we talked to
them both about the mission
it will open a new era commercial space
flight
does it mean something to you guys in
this new age to be the first
after you come back and it's successful
you know bob and i can go hang out
someplace and have a beer and
and maybe then we can reflect on you
know all those things
now after nine years of relying on the
russians
america is back in the business of
launching and landing astronauts
took years to get here we brought the
capability back to america
and we came home safely to our families
time for that beer hurley talked about
we can all toast to that for cbs this
morning
mark straussman atlanta